to the public at all so that's really
the first time ever and so Gollum is an
epic story driven action adventure in
the world of lord of rings Lord of the
Rings yes and um so and as we are like
like story people we wanted to tell the
story of Gollum because like you know
it's obvious to do the like big
characters but with the with Golem he's
connecting so many dots his story behind
the scenes connecting so many dots so
that's that makes a lot of sense to to
really show what's Happening behind the
scenes in Mordor in Northwood in support
so so let's start yeah no this is great
again big Lord of the Rings fans I would
love to know about these connecting
grades he's an absolutely hilarious
character yeah so yeah so again as far
as the the game type is it actually very
interesting stealth What type of game
yeah so so it's it's um I thought it's
an action adventure so so with stealth
element and
um and with a lot of cool stuff also in
there it's more fun but but still
accessible it's it's um it's more about
um exploring the story of The Lord of
the Rings and the lore we have hitting a
lot of stuff in all the crevices of the
game and you can see stuff like all over
the place so that's um so so it's
actually a game for for the Lord of the
Rings lovers I really want to see some
easy to you know play a story that's
behind the the scenes basically many
times so so that's yeah so that's really
cool because again like for people who
are fail in the series and people you
get those World bikes you get those
connected braids and that's very cool is
really expensive it is so this is why we
have like like two guys who are doing
the story they have phds on on
literature on talking laws so they they
really it's amazing
that's great that's great that's great
yeah you know no they really so so I
read the books like 11 times now so I'm
a big fan as well so very happy and so
so good to um to be able to to do a game
on a lot of dreams and um so so yeah but
they know stuff you know like the
discussions we have yeah I like like a
whole series about you know like like a
movie series or other stuff so it's
really really intense because they
really mean it so of course you can see
the battleship first of all it looks
really good yes love the movement
already but yeah but Gollum is hilarious
to me
and always have to to look up a little
bit in between and look outside so this
is just a tutorial showing how the how
the game is working so they will be we
will be coming to all the favorite
places of The Lord of the Rings so um
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah so I'm sorry
yeah you will go to model one and you
will go to um to Murphy tomorrow maybe
maybe some other places I um
the fans of the series will be uh
excited to indeed so so I have you know
I really had to um when I started
playing because I that's a great thing
about working in the publisher right so
you can start playing early on and it
was like seeing what's happening there
so so it wouldn't show me all right
secretive about it so um yeah that was
some so yeah there's a lot of stuff
hidden in there so that's awesome can I
ask what are those like objects that are
forming on the sides like you see like a
fish and a clam what are those that are
forming on like okay so so you can um
only has this lowering cloth but it's a
very special Lauren cloth so you can
hide fish and and then like like food
and
you regain Health
um and
um and you need to go up up there and
then go you can jump up again on that
ledge there's a ledge over there to the
right to the right
to the right yeah there you go and I'll
go up there
there you go and then you can can yeah
I mean he's a 500 year old character
right he's like he has survived so long
and he's so strong he's so agile he's
like like he's like really a man and
then so so of course we needed to to
have him how can he survive in in the I
mean rural so in the in the shadowlands
no in the Misty Mountains without you
know without being like like super
athletic so he is super athletic and um
yeah
which I realized was part of this game
which is really cool yeah indeed what
type of time frame is this actually
placed in the Pokemon Universe yeah it
is actually it's it's um it starts from
like kind of three years after he meets
Bilbo okay so um when he leaves so when
he leaves Misty Mountains okay so in
search of his crashes okay and
um and um might be
um like the game might be ending around
when the
um oh what's the fellowship so the
fellowship is in um nice um it goes goes
through maurya maybe maybe I don't know
so um let's so that's basically the the
timeline for the guys exactly so again
since that is like a time frame like
that it's kind of known to the you know
the Tolkien you know Universe yeah is
there like there's a lot of like
possibly doing like some type of like
co-op with with Bilbo or anything like
that during during this time or I should
say like with uh with any of the other
characters oh yeah yeah of course of
course you meet that some yeah I don't
so of course you meet meet some
characters and
um will interact with them and in a very
special way because we so and we try to
design the game in terms of
um like from Golem's view so so yeah
from his perspective exactly so because
it's like um because he sees the world
very different right so he has enemies
all over the place right he has like so
so Mordor is his enemy right so on and
and the elves as well right so everybody
captures him he's always out of life so
um this is how we how we designed the
idea about the game like you know golden
being on you know like he doesn't
understand why why people react on him
like that so and we try to keep on by an
app well one thing off the bat I really
like that the the game is like I mean
the Grafton style two guys have chosen
yeah perspective what injury
yeah yeah that's that's unreal four plus
something so I'm I'm not a technical guy
so unreal plus something custom
potential yeah yeah exactly yeah no yeah
exactly so so Tyler broke his legs
so oh man this I I can't tell you but
that's what when I played for the first
time and there's also so on PC and of
course on PlayStation and on the other
platforms there will be
um
there will be achievements of course
okay yes but there's there's one so
funny oh my God it's like the
achievements like everybody who knows a
little bit about the Lord of the Rings
will love it I I promise you so that's
really so good so he has a really unique
achievements tied to the Lord okay yeah
yeah that's cool so again we've noticed
again a lot of stuff a lot of climbing
park more yeah now yeah so so this is
not only the tutorial so it seems like
it's like all the time they're cool but
it's like um this is because this is a
level to learn the control right right
so so at later levels
dragons
look at that it's a nice Golden Stick
it's like you need to take stuff okay
cool sorry
yeah so you would say outside there's
more different types of mechanics
outside of it yeah outside of the
tutorial yeah yeah of course they are
like so what's important about school
economy is not only golo right so
gollumin says well it's smeagle as well
so so there's a lot of things that that
surround and that's very important
um for the game that's that you know
like the the um like the two
personalities that are in Donald Trump
right we have that as a gameplay element
as well so you have to decide at certain
places
at some points at some points um there
will be like just fun stuff right you
know you can throw down a base on some
Elves and stuff so but then you can
react as Gollum and then you know so so
almost I've got to interrupt you almost
like Gollum in in Spiegel almost like a
good age or bad age like kind of yeah
like kind of that yeah you know it's
always like like fighting um so Golem is
a
um Golem is a Survivor right he he is he
is the Survivor and and smeagle is more
like he's looking for friends actually
right and then he's like like a like a
regular Hobbit you know like as he is
like
yeah so um yeah and that's um so and and
it goes so far so that's fun just fun
decisions but also that um the actions
that will change the the run of the
story
um not like super huge but there are
changes and it will affect characters
nice it will affect characters
oh that's awesome and I love stuff like
that because again some flight decision
making again it's I won't say like
affect the entire ending but it can it
affects certain gameplay elements
including the characters yeah oh that's
cool yeah but this is what it's about
you need to go through that um little K
fair but there's like as you see here
there's a lot of stuff um like hidden of
his story off of the lore and you can
find hidden items as well so we can
select stuff like and then everybody
will recognize immediately who knows a
little bit of the books or the films
right so
um that's that's um of course you need
to do that yeah no this is really cool I
love the fact you guys are taking this
perspective from this character very
unique character yeah no you can review
with this this the golden thing is like
because like many people ask you a white
golden but it is like really an
interesting character he's an
interesting story and he's seeing things
like like
um from a very different perspective so
that's a really new take on that and why
all the while you know being like really
true to galore yeah that's very
important to us and I'm so happy it's
like that so like yeah I know it I know
it's early but do we have like an idea
of probably like our first like gameplay
length or I was like what do we call it
what are we going for yeah we're like 20
25 hours
so yeah we are so a single player
um
single player game
um you don't have to drop in buttons
just just run against it while while
it's printing
so
um
the question was again sorry well we
talk about gameplay
and the exact nature so just in general
like as far as the team how long has it
has the game been in development so the
game has been in development like I
think for three and a half years now
something like that so yeah that has
been like uh lots of State lots of stuff
going on in the development and you know
you have seen it we have like like I'm
gonna try to
um you know we you know like it took a
little bit longer than we planned you
know it's a new team that's all together
and Corona didn't help with development
as well you know like all the games have
have delays now yeah so it's getting
better now and still no no pressing
button just running yeah there you go
almost almost
yeah
any combat section because he's yeah
strictly focused on yeah you know
movement sneaking things yeah so we we
have like like there's not not real
comeback to be honest but there's like
um so you can stream
[Laughter]
need to jump to the opposite so we're
still working on the camera so it's not
his fault entirely right maybe a little
bit right
we got it we got it just X just jumping
to the other side trust ah okay see
that's the things we are still working
on this is why it's better but yeah
or NPCs in in situations where they will
will be dying like for example um you
will be um the one or
um you you one or two Kill by strangling
and the other you you make throw the
light out so there's a light source and
slow the lineup so it guitars and then
someone on eight legs is coming
getting coming to that org and stuff
like this yes yes
so they are really like what we don't
didn't have yet too much is like like
his hiding skills yeah so um he's hiding
a lot um of course in the bushes and
stuff so go up there so and then wait
wait to pray on his enemy or or wait out
stay in the bushes oh you got to be in
the bushes yeah oh yes is it is
[Laughter]
all right so we gotta get we got to get
our steep holes
just through there okay okay
yeah and then you go there and then you
try to hide from from
foreign
[Music]
it starts getting orange and then when
it starts getting red and then when red
they they see you and and want to um
just jump no drop down drop oh yeah and
some more problems we're going to close
it here most likely let's get one drop
let's get that shot yeah let's see that
drop yeah okay cool cool
so if you go around that they have this
very nice so this is what we do look
around a bit a little bit so you have
over a little bit more maybe around so
um you have the you have these you know
these these things that a little bit to
the other times
keep going keep going keep going yeah so
and then we'll move a little bit more
out so you have these these these pork
encampments and stuff so we have stuff
like everywhere you can look at and find
items to go there so um extra
exploration yeah exploration is a big
big part of that again this is just a
very
um straight level because of the
tutorial yeah the character getting the
players yeah exactly I know he has a
magical loincloth yes but let's let's we
have like like is there any other
clothes and stuff that he ends up
getting or is he just get to use as is
the whole entire time yeah that's
basically um so let's let's so so we
again there we stay true to the lore and
um yeah so and yeah so this is now a
scene where he's like um he can decide
like two things and because you drive
too high he's too visible to do once
yeah that's Sauron so um
yeah so so you're always always hiding
yeah
[Music]
foreign
already so we found like a really we
just found really good friend Royal life
we've found really nice
um
nice voices for them to voice actors
which is some really
um uh I think we I think this is
something which I really like so he the
voice actor for forgotomy really makes
like like The Duality of the character
he makes it like really really well this
is awesome love the attention detail
yeah what we're doing for the lord lord
of rings absolutely love this the
character is hilarious to me so again
first time seeing it here in packs yes
super excited what do you have to tell
the people who want to know more get
their hands on it support the game what
do they do yeah they can do follow us on
social media check out the game on
golemgame.com and
um coming out soon this year nice
something oh this is awesome
so baby breathability um the decision is
to be done and but we will be available
on PlayStation 5 PlayStation 4 Xbox
series X and S replace the Xbox One and
PC
and later on switch as well okay any
potential steam deck support maybe of
course yeah that's that's what we are so
so it's not done yet but yes that's the
plan of definitely absolute pleasure
Lord of the Rings guys for everyone here
first packs is Debut go check it out
Smeagol is in the building
you guys cheers
[Music]